i have questions for students,
what about Sarah Wagenknecht
spoke and thought long and hard,
what party color it actually has.
I would have put that in my tie.
well,
she has such a strange sunrise,
because all other colors were already occupied,
she told Me.
but the conversation has become very exciting,
about how she looks at traffic light policy,
what she thinks of the ukrain war
and how it can be finished.
and at the very end she betrayed us,
where she buys her costumes.
so who cares,
who must see this conversation
and from front to back.
WWW.
News.
Point D. E.
really exciting conversation.
Sarah Wagenknecht,
the head of alliance Sarah Wagenknecht,
the only party in Germany,
where the name is program.